taiwan's not a third world country but
the dollar goes very very far over there
you could live third world if you want
oh really that's what's dope about it
like Taiwan they have like all the
regular stores that you see in America
if you want to live like the island life
my dad did and buy your groceries from
the farmers market my uncle's a dentist
there he makes white collar money right
but then he buys all his from the
farmers market swap meat even at slacks
and all that and he says his expenses
for the whole year was like 11,000 a
whole year car that's why did that's a m
they have Costco they have Costco too
but that to them that's expensive
Costco's expensive why why would I do
that if I could just go to Farmers
Market and buy a batch of leaks for five
nickels or whatever the farmers
markets here are expensive that's what
my dad did